a dying star enjoying the last moments
of its life
a scarlet ball of white hot plasma whose
prominence is lost through a cold vacuum
in its agony
two potent powers are its struggle in
its depths
they now force the star to expand to
dozens of times its size then make it
shrink again only to flare up with new
energy
one of these transformations is going to
be the last one but no one can foretell
the exact instance with any certainty
this epic site could be enjoyed by space
traveler approaching cw leonis
a pulsating red giant which has been
thrashing in a death agony for thousands
of years
the first in outer space
650 light years away from the earth
there lies irc plus 10 to 16.
a majestic star also known as cw leonis
its radius at its pulsation peak may
reach
560 times that of the sun which is about
2.6 times the distance from the earth to
our apparent star
with cw leonis hypothetically placed in
the middle of our system all the planets
as far as mars would find themselves
under its surface
which would even brush the inner
boundary of the asteroid belt
incidentally the star's mass is not that
great roughly 1.5 to 4 solar masses
its surface temperature is just 2
300 kelvin or about 2 000 degrees
celsius but due to its impressive
dimensions the star emits on average
eight and a half thousand times more
energy than our sun
like any other red giant cw leonis is in
its final life stage
its age hasn't been defined precisely
but it is estimated to be several
billion years
it is assumed that in its solid days cw
leonis was a white blue star with a mass
three to five times that of the sun
however by one billion years ago a great
part of the celestial body's hydrogen
had burned out and transformed into
helium
slowly settling in the star's center
the helium ousted all the remaining
hydrogen and formed a scorching hot core
which did not participate in any
thermonuclear reactions
this process typical for all stars whose
masses close to that of the sun is the
starting point for a star's
transformation into a red giant
the star's inner pressure causes it to
expand to great proportions which
renders the outer layers more rarefied
and unstable
the space object's diameter grows to be
dozens of times greater with its color
gradually assuming a blood red hue
a thermonuclear reaction still takes
place in the star's depths which causes
the pressure and temperature of the
stelloplasma to increase
at a certain point this unleashes a
chain reaction of nuclear fusion where
helium nuclei are transformed into
carbon
this is the so-called helium flash
it is a complex multi-level physical
process that dramatically transforms the
star's inner structure
with its score incredibly heating up its
outer layers on the contrary cool off
and darken
there are currently great amounts of
carbon in cw leonis but its mass isn't
sufficient to hit the next level of
nuclear synthesis
as a result the thermonuclear combustion
in the object's interior becomes
unstable the stellar matter gradually
cools off and shrinks under the
influence of gravitation
this heats up the star's interior again
and the reaction is unleashed with a new
force
after receiving a new portion of thermal
energy
the stellar matter expands again and the
combustion dies down
it is assumed that this cyclic process
underlies the occasional changes of the
star's luminosity
cw leonis has a
649-day pulsation cycle and with the
luminosity at its peak is 11
300 times brighter than the sun with the
luminosity at its lowest meanwhile the
object emits
6250 times more energy than the sun
at the moment of contraction the upper
layers of stella mata partly detach
themselves from the star
this forms a carbon-oxygen gas nebula
that the star is enveloped in
according to some estimates cw leonis
loses 4 times 10 to the power of 22 tons
of material every year on account of
this process and amount approximately
seven times the mass of the earth
observations show that the circumstellar
nebula is not less than 69 000 years old
and its mass is about 1.5 times that of
the sun
as for its size it reaches 84 000
astronomical units
the nebula has an elaborate structure
with bulges and pockets of gas as well
as half arcs and irregular rings
it is posited that these formations
appeared due to magnetic activity and
stellar wind generated by the unstable
star close by
the chemical composition of the cloud cw
leonis is shrouded in is of great
interest to explorers
spectral analysis data reveals it to
contain around 70 different chemical
compounds for example carbon dioxide
water and ammonia to name but a few
there are also quite a lot of elements
from the upper part of mendeleev's
periodic table
right down to iron
cw leonis may have had planets in the
past but they appear to have been
swallowed up early on at the stage of
expansion in any event years of
observations did not reveal distinct
traces of their existence in the past
what was registered was subtle changes
in the star's orbit back in 1994 and
more recently in 2017 mysterious shifts
of mata were detected in the cloud of
gas and dust enveloping the star
some small red dwarf orbiting the giant
could well account for these phenomena
although attempts to detect its
radiation have so far been unsuccessful
this could be due to the nebula close by
which disperses and reflects the energy
flow from sources of light located
nearby
this phenomenon camouflages any objects
in the immediate environs and prevents
them from being accurately recognized
the mass of cw leonis's hypothetical
stellar companion is assumed to be
definitely smaller than that of the sun
and it should take it approximately a
hundred years to complete a full orbit
around the giant
another outstanding feature is a
comparatively high water content in the
star's environs and envelope
at first it was posited that the star
would melt and swallow up icy comets as
it expanded
however observations carried out in 2009
showed the temperature of some spectral
lines to reach a thousand kelvin which
is possible only on condition that water
vapor forms actually in the upper layers
of the giant
this fact did not fit in the model of
red giant's structure accepted at the
time according to which all oxygen and
stellar matter necessary for water
synthesis must be used up completely to
produce carbon monoxide
a new hypothesis was put forward to
account for the witnessed phenomena
which stated that molecules of silicon
oxides and carbon are destroyed by a
powerful ultraviolet radiation
after that the released oxygen reacts
with hydrogen and therefore scorching
hot water vapor
the weakness of this hypothesis is on
the failure to account for the source of
ultraviolet radiation
reactions like that may occur only in
rather high temperatures
that is within stellar matter
however it is practically impervious to
cosmic rays
this paradox may be explained by yet
another assumption since the star is
unstable large ruptures and low density
areas occasionally occur on its surface
where ultraviolet radiation is not
blocked out that effectively
the water vapor's overall mass in the
star's atmosphere and outer layers is
estimated at several quintillion tons
enormous though this figure may seem in
fact water accounts for just around a
billionth of the stars of raw mass
according to today's notions of stellar
evolution being a red giant cw leonis is
in its autumn years now it will deplete
its stellar fuel in the next 10 to 30
000 years after which it will discard
its outer layers following a powerful
explosion
it will transform into an incredibly hot
and dense space object
a white dwarf
its mass will be roughly eighty percent
that of the sun and its temperature will
reach several million degrees in the
first seconds after the transformation
however with no energy source it is
destined to slowly and irrevocably fade
in the course of billions of years to
follow
eventually the celestial body will be
almost invisible against the background
of cosmic emptiness when it becomes a
mysterious black dwarf
but this will not happen anytime soon
the shock wave and the mind-boggling
temperature in the epicenter will
generate new elements that are not to be
found in a star's interior
for example uranium gold and lead
they will later become part of new
celestial objects
millions of years later yet radioactive
decay will heat the planet's interiors
melt the ice and saturate the oceans
with micro elements thus creating
conditions for the genesis of life
the universe is constantly evolving and
global cataclysms and destruction are an
inalienable part of this process
but at the end of every storm there are
fresh rays of light
[Music]
you